o que eu vejo é que tem pouca maturidade
de produto no na questão de impacto de
entender como é que eu impacto O que que
eu vou funcionar produto né não é arte é
Ciência Então como você transforma isso
em ciência e
metrificação mais claras né
Eh então me parece Se eu olhar né as
duas As duas disciplinas design eu vejo
uma disciplina mais organizada que o
produto Oi tudo bem com você meu nome é
Paulo shod e sejam bem-vindos ao Project
gurus o podcast que a voz por trás dos
produtos e comigo hoje Fernanda faria
que vai falar sobre maturidade
eh de produtos e também eu vou cobrá-la
pelo uso indevido da minha imagem lá no
Zé Deli tudo bem Fê tudo bom e você Tudo
bem também eh Ô Fê antes da gente
começar Qual que é a definição de
maturidade maturidade de produto é
quando e para mim é num caminho de
quando não existe mais a separação entre
produto negócio e design né na verdade
tá todo mundo olhando pro mesmo lugar né
o roadmap ele é muito encaixado com a
estratégia a gente tá visando o futuro
tá conectado com a estratégia os times
que a gente chama de multifuncionais não
são mais só produc Trio ali que funciona
né você expandiu tem tem um ponto muito
importante aí também é quando o design
se torna estratégico que isso também
muda o patamar de como a empresa toda
pode se conectar com o consumidor hoje
hoje você acha que olhando pro pra nossa
comunidade pra nossa área você acha que
falta maturidade no nos times de
produtos e se você for comparar com os
times de design os times de design são
mais maduros do que os de produtos da
nossa área não só do do não é olhando
pra nossa área como um todo
eh o que eu vejo é que tem pouca
maturidade de produto no na questão de
impacto de entender como é que eu
impacto O que que eu vou funcionar
produto né não é arte é Ciência Então
como você transforma isso em ciência e
metrificação mais claras né
Eh então me parece Se eu olhar né as
duas As duas disciplinas design eu vejo
uma disciplina mais organizada que
produto e se a gente for pensar produto
tem existe há menos tempo do que design
também então é natural essa diferença
entre né o estágio de um de um Capítulo
e o estágio de outro Capítulo
maturidade como no papel tá vou a gente
falou sobre as áreas eu vou falar sobre
agora o profissional Você acredita que
falta uma maturidade essa esse é o ponto
né de saber
conectar muitas vezes as pessoas de
produtos não precisam ir ir pra Rua
descobrir vezes já tem um backlog
lá e se ela fizesse um exercício de
tentar conectar o que já tem no backlog
com as métricas de negócio criar essa
não vou falar narrativa para não ficar
falando storytelling mas criar essa essa
narrativa de E aí eu vou dar um exemplo
aqui tá Pô o time de engenharia quer que
eu faça quer que a gente desenvolve o
monitoramento na plataforma muitas
pessoas de produtos vai olhar vai fal
assim pô não vou fazer é coisa técnica
não gera valor pro cliente só que a
maturidade vem de entender que o
monitoramento faz sentido porque a
necessidade do negócio antecipar
problemas na plataforma o que gera uma
redução de ligações que gera redução de
custo Mas tem uma outra coisa assim
pensa que isso impacta direto no cliente
Qual que é o custo de aquisição de um
cliente na hora que a plataforma tem uma
instabilidade você não tem não tá
monitorando etc o fato de ter uma
instabilidade se você for medir usar
cessat por exemplo para para medir a
cessat vai ter o impacto de 1 P5 1 p me
da cessat significa que a minha retenção
daquele corrot ao invés de ser 45% vai
vai ser 25% então eu tô jogando 20% do
que eu tô tendo de aquisição fora então
não é só sobre pensar é também No
Impacto no negócio mas é pensar em
Caramba isso aqui afeta eu joguei
dinheiro fora e eu não quero que o
consumidor tenha essa experiência Você
acha que falta essa essa essa questão do
do do Olhar acho que falta quando aí
você tá numa cadeira de CPO Você é a
dona do Rolê o quem der
falta F falta você acredita que falta um
pouco de um olhar
holístico para as pessoas de produtos eu
acho que
tem tem um lado assim as pessoas você
tem um grupo de pessoas que ainda é
muito teórica e
Sonhadora colocar nesse nesse grupo que
não produto tem que ter liberdade
produto é uma teoria a gente tem ter os
noss conseguir usar tem um outro lado de
produto que eu acho que são dois
extremos assim vou pegar o pêndulo tem
um outro lado de produto que é muito
vamos passar tesque no no gira Escreve a
história perfeita tal e passa e na
verdade é um grande analista de
requisito do passado né Se a gente for
pensar para mim o meio de campo assim é
quando as pessoas pessoas começam a
entender que o papel da pessoa de
produto é
contexto e contexto é isso que eu acabei
de te falar do impacto do monitoramento
né caramba eu sei que então eu tenho o
contexto de que quando a plataforma cai
afeta um ponto na cessat esse um ponto
na cessat Me Custa 20% do coror Esses
são as ligações que que eu vejo que né a
gente evolu
muito se a gente olhar para trás mas a
gente também teve um Boom de entrada na
área E aí precisa esperar naturalmente
as pessoas amadurecerem sobre esse
contexto e sobre essas métricas como que
elas se falam né e o que que por isso
que eu acho que é Ciência e não arte
nardinho rápido e mega importante para
você que tá ouvindo esse episódio na pm3
Você aprende com quem faz por sinal a
Fernanda faria também é uma das instr as
na formação de pro leadership a
metodologia da pm3 combina conteúdos On
Demand e práticas para que você evolua
no seu ritmo e tem mais você que tá
ouvindo esse episódio tem 10% de
desconto em todos os cursos da pm3 com o
cupom pro gurus pro gurus tudo junto
Baixe também o guia para evoluir na
carreira de produtos o link para você
contratar um dos cursos e o link para
você baixar o guia para evoluir na
carreira de produtos estão na descrição
tá bom Quais são os principais sinais de
que a integração entre o produto e o
design Está Madura em em uma empresa e
porque você no no primeiro meap de
produtos na na Globo você levou né o
case da da maturidade e tal não sei o qu
o link do meap para você o link
justamente da palestra dela da do time
ali da palestra da F tá na descrição
aqui do episódio
Quai Quais são os principais sinais
dessa integração e quais são os sintomas
de imaturidade você já falou né alguns
mas como você
eh mapeia isso
ã na empresa porque tem muito debate
sobre né ah
eh aí vai uma crítica crítica Rogerinho
que
é muito muita liderança terceiriza o
rolê terceiriza a responsabilidade f
assim ó o time não entrega aí ao invés
de ele olhar e falar assim pera aí deixa
eu fazer um trabalho aqui de entender o
por que o time não tá entregando aí você
pergunta Ô por que o time ah falta
maturidade ah a gente tem que contratar
seniors do mercado não é bem assim né é
eu vou dizer que o é e não é tá
é aonde Não é porque realmente o líder
tem ter o papel de na hora que ele tá
montando uma equipe ele ser capaz de
equilibrar os Skills então ele precisa
saber eu preciso ter um Blender aqui uma
mistura específica ele precisa pensar
Qual que é essa mistura
e o que eu digo o que eu digo que é
também um problema que eu digo sobre
maturidade é as pessoas saberem mais
sobre qual que é o papel de produto Qual
que é o papel de design real naquela
organização porque isso muda de
organização para
organização e essa necessidade de
adaptar que eu acho que as pessoas que
são mais flexíveis adaptáveis são as
pessoas que conseguem circular mais
nesse ambiente e aí entendendo Qual que
é o papel né então vou contar um pouco
do que a gente fez basicamente eu
cheguei eu tive tinha entendimento do
que que era o papel e tinha aqui um
objetivo futuro a onde a gente queria
chegar que esse o papel realmente que
produto deveria fazer só que isso é uma
maratona é uma jornada você não vai
chegar e nossa em três meses não mudei a
empresa ó que lugar horrível vou sair né
Então você tem que olhar isso como uma
jornada eu falo muito que é Uma Jornada
para mim de 5 anos eu tô na metade dela
E aí como que eu crio os indicadores
para monitorar essa evolução Então o que
eu vejo nessa hora é a gente como líder
muitas vezes também tem dificuldade de
deixar claro Quais são os pontos que são
os pontos críticos que não tem a
maturidade em si né que não tem aquele
Skill uma vez que você consegue mapear
você consegue trabalhar e eu acho louco
assim é acho curioso né quando a galera
vem nossa tem tudo isso aqui de problema
você não vai resolver tudo isso resolve
um é
daqui seis meses você resolve outro você
fica angustiado ansiedade fica como lá
em cima mas tem terapia para isso tem
medicação e isso ajuda você a a lidar
melhor com eu entendo os deficiências
mas eu não vou resolver tudo porque essa
frase né Precisa de pessoas mais Sênior
significa Ah eu quero resolver tudo de
uma vez que eu vou contratar todo mundo
do mercado que sabe tudo isso daqui vou
trazer para cá mas não existe essa qu de
pessoas que sab tudo no mercado e também
você pode trazer essas pessoas no
mercado sem ter construído o ambiente
para que essas pessoas que sabem tudo
consiga executar né O que sabe esse é um
problema também né rapaz aí é um outro
problema que acontece porque se você mas
ó eu vou fazer um contraponto pras
pessoas de produto tá que é acho que é
Nossa responsabilidade
quando você chega em uma empresa e você
lê o ambiente é entender Qual que é o
papel exatamente o que eu falei Qual que
é o papel que tem agora tá bom mas eu
não quero esse ambiente Eu quero um
ambiente
Y A gente precisa montar um plano para
fazer isso às vezes vai ser possível às
vezes não né mas
o esse espaço ele também precisa ser
construído porque você as pessoas em
geral acham que né fazer um produto é
muitas vezes escrever um requisito e
entregar uma tela e pronto o botão tá lá
né se a gente for no simples e no
simples é isso que as pessoas acham
então se eu tiver uma fábrica aqui
fazendo analogia de fábrica eu vou eu
quero SC eu faço várias latinhas de SC e
vão na linha de produção agora quando
você tá falando sobre um produto
digital você pode fazer um produto que
fala beleza eu quero escola então botar
aqui um botão da escola
pronto mas no fundo quando você faz isso
é porque você quer resolver alguma coisa
então necessita de aprofundamento Mas se
você quiser fazer só o botão você pode
fazer não faz
diferença para quem tá vendo a entrega
porque se o steak holder pediu o botão e
você entregou o botão
golaço mas depois você não vai entregar
o resultado E aí você vai ser cobrado
porque porque não entregou o
resultado então quando eu vejo né muita
gente fazendo Ah não eu entreguei porque
pediram isso e tal e já fiz isso também
para mim são as piores decisões que eu
tomei na vida foi quando eu tomei a
decisão de fazer exatamente o que
queriam sem aprofundar
eh para ter mais contexto daquele porquê
então o TDH se perdeu mas o
raciocínio era basicamente pensando que
tem um lado que a pessoa de produto Tem
que criar esse ambiente e esse ambiente
você vai expandindo às vezes ele é num
microambiente E aí o fato de você
conseguir atuar mais eh estratégico e
falar né conversar com os stakeholders e
ser empático com stakeholder é o que vai
fazer você conseguir se destacar
voltando a a a a questão da da
maturidade que tá tudo englobando a o
nosso papo aqui um um dos pontos é o
o fazer esse
mapeamento eh se chama assessment eh ou
a de uma pesquisa 360 caceta Como
que como que foi esse processo e essa
construção eh dos times de de de produto
Design da AMBEV porque a gente fala Zé
delivere Mas você cuida não só do Zé né
você cuida do mundo do tabá também não
todo n do Zé e do cadá eh deliver é o
equivalente do Zé delivery em outros 10
países da América Latina não é isso tá
bom 10 só 10 S apenas 10 e
ou Calma é tipo War você tá conquistando
o mundo eh aos poucos e aí entra o e
calma já abre várias perguntas na minha
cabeça como que é feito o processo e a
construção dessa pesquisa desse sment
dos times de produtos do do da AMBEV eh
times de produtos de design e aí a
segunda pergunta que eu posso fazer
depois mas eu já vou deixar aqui que
é 10 10 países Então são culturas
diferentes contextos diferentes isso
impacta o primeiro ponto da sua pergunta
Pensa numa pesquisa de clima de
engagement de engajamento pesquisa de
clima você quer medir isso existe há
muito tempo não é difícil você quer
medir Se as pessoas estão motivadas se
as pessoas estão felizes com salário
então você tem os tópicos que você do
que você quer medir E você tem as
perguntas que você faz que são daquele
contexto pras pessoas responderem então
quando a gente fala de eh de medir a
maturidade A lógica é basicamente a
mesma né Por quê O que eu tô o que eu tô
dizendo é eu vou fazer
eh aqui numa sés
perguntas que achei bonito que você
falou eu fala pesquisa mas assessment
bonito aqui no assessment perguntas
conectadas àquele tópico então por
exemplo se eu quero saber de práticas e
consumer insit ou prática e
experimentação eu vou fazer perguntas
sobre experimentação então de
experimentação por exemplo tem sete
perguntas para falar para dar nota de
experimentação
pessoas respondem aquelas perguntas e
aquilo gera uma nota para você conseguir
avaliar experimentação então a gente
criou nessa lógica né e não foi bem a
gente não criou sozinho eu falo isso
muito com né o Rodrigo Medeiros que do
meu que era do meu time ele foi agora
eh
ele Ele estudou bastante na hora que a
gente estava criando então a ideia era
justamente ter uma métrica que eu
conseguisse dizer
qual que era a maturidade e com isso a
gente conseguir mensurar a evolução
porque você consegue perceber a evolução
né porque você vê que as entregas estão
com mais qualidade que tá impactando
muito mais o negócio que o negócio tá
crescendo etc mas na hora que você tá
falando com stakeholders normalmente as
pessoas querem saber o dado Então quando
você fala evoluímos de um para três em
experimentação nossa bastante Então você
começa a ter outro tipo de argumentação
por isso que é importante medir a
segunda pergunta que é de culturas
diferentes o produto ele é feito de
forma
centralizada com product laons em cada
país Então imagina que desses 10
mercados os maiores mercados são México
Colômbia
eh peru
e Equador por exemplo Esses são os
maiores mercados né que tem então você
vai olhar com mais atenção pros quatro
maiores os seis vão acabar entrando no
dia a dia mas na hora que você tá
montando por exemplo Ah vamos montar o
roadmap de Q1 é uma loucura porque tem
muitos objetivos e a gente tenta juntar
para fun lá mas são culturas diferentes
tem países que são mais
diretos se a gente olhar todos são
latinos então Isso facilita a nossa vida
talvez na hora que tiver um não Latino a
gente começa a sentir mais diferença
o e como e como que faz essa evolução Ô
Fei acho que muitas muitas empresas e
muitas
lideranças elas não fazem essa pesquisa
ponto vão jogam no no no fácil que é
aquele aquele cenário que eu falei que é
falta maturidade Vamos no mercado eh Eh
vamos no mercado a gente compra uma dusa
de seniors dois PDS e um um agilista só
para agilizar as coisas
eh mas não é assim né então primeiro
processo é você fazer essa pesquisa
360 Pelo que eu entendi e que tá lá no
no no na sua palestra lá no meap é é um
360 normal de performance de de clima
que é a pessoa se
se se auto vai lá responde como que ela
se vê como que o time vê ela e como que
as outras áreas vê ela certo é
basicamente assim deixa eu eu vou abrir
para você ver um uma acho que vai ficar
mais fácil de de de compartilhar e as
pessoas podem ver também depois eu dou
um jeito de compartilhar com todos então
você que tá assistindo pelo pelo YouTube
ou ouvindo e assistindo pelo Spotify
você vai ver agora aqui a pesquisa não a
pesquisa né mas o o o como que a que a
Fê tá fazendo e esse trabalho de
maturidade lá no no
naev você que tá no Apple podcast e
outros tocadores de Podcast
eh vai lá no YouTube e para assistir ou
assiste pelo planilha para
você para você compartilhar com a
comunidade vai tá na vai tá na descrição
do episódio boa aí o que que a gente faz
consumer insite o time mantém o um
diálogo constante com as usuárias para
entender suas necessidades e
preferências o time Analisa dados de
tendências e padrões de comportamento o
time tem fácil acesso a dados
comportamentais a equipe colabora com
time de dados para obter insite a voz e
necessidade E aí isso daqui tudo as
pessoas votam de um a cinco
no cinco excelente fazem isso com
excelência e um não faz mas quando você
fala eh as pessoas você tá falando
pessoas de produto do time que votam tá
bom elas informam se isso tá acontecendo
ou não assim como por exemplo Numa
pesquisa de engajamento você responderia
Ah você sente orgulho de trabalhar na
empresa você responde sim não muito
pouco é a mesma lógica aplicada aqui e
são várias perguntas porque às vezes a
pessoa fala não em uma uma nota muito
ruim em outra mas a outra que a frase é
bem parecida inclusive manda quatro
Então essa é uma forma de você também eh
tirar um pouco o viés de alguns de
alguns pontos então nessa pesquisa os
stakeholders e as outras áreas não
participam não participam só o time de
produto tá bom e o de design né você faz
a mesma coisa pro design design é é São
perguntas diferentes para design mas sim
o de design Quem criou foi a Cláudia
mgan e eu e esse eu me inspirei nela
assim para fazer outro produto né a
Cláudia criou pro design aí ela me
mostrou falei nossa isso aqui é muito
bom muito poderoso precis Vamos fazer um
de produto também é o r fez e assim a
gente começou a medir os dois a gente tá
medindo tem mais de um ano já e é bem
legal ver a evolução o o como que é
feito pos
eh essa análise e essa definição do tipo
você explicou um pouco lá na na na
palestra mas com certeza já evoluiu né
foram do anos quase sim eh como que você
faz esse pos porque Ok a pessoa colocou
cinco três 2 1 eh quro tá enfim o que
isso significa eh
eh penso o seguinte vamos lá quando a
gente começou a
medir o que a gente tinha como né níveis
de maturidade que foi exatamente o que
eu apresentei lá na no meetup da Globo
pto com a um tempão da Globo né
Eh era essa evolução e a gente entendia
que a gente estava muito nessa nesse
nível dois o designer era muito mais um
workshop então ah vamos fazer um
workshop para definir o World Map etc
Então a partir do momento que você
começa a medir você sabe saber onde você
tá bem e onde você não tá né então por
exemplo Putz eu sei aqui de
experimentação para 3.4 queria tá em
quatro em experimentação então o que que
eu vou fazer eu preciso direcionar os
esforços para a experimentação funcionar
melhor E aí eu vou dar o exemplo do que
a gente fez assim várias coisas ali
cresceram como consequência mas de
experimentação a gente contratou o
ex-diretor da Booking para ser consultor
da gente por 3 meses para ajudar a gente
a tirar do zero né todo o conceito de
experimentação organização documentação
O que que a gente tinha que fazer etc
ferramental investiu em ferramental pro
time e depois investiu em trazer mais
conceitos e aí criou tem um número de
qualidade do experimento então eu sei se
a gente criou uns critérios que
experimento tá com qualidade ou tá sem
qualidade E aí a partir disso você então
o que que a gente fez eu quero melhorar
a experimentação Quais são os mecanismos
que eu preciso criar para melhorar a
experimentação esses daqui a partir do
momento que os mecanismos começam a
rodar a nota ela aumenta porque as
pessoas começam a olhar e falam Caramba
você não tá pedindo para eu fazer
experimentação e falando Ah vai lá faz
dá teu jeito você tá falando faça mais
experimentação mas a gente vai que
trazer a pessoa para poder ensinar a
gente vai trazer o a né é a metodologia
que vai trazer ferramental E aí com isso
as pessoas começam a fazer mais booking
né booking.com é o maior case de de
empresa com cultura de teste e
experimentação é bizarro
eh o volume que eles conseguem fazer eh
de teste e experimentação
simultaneamente é uma coisa
que não vejo muitos muitas empresas
conseguindo tendo estrutura para tal eh
e também difícil PR caramba fazer né o
volume que eles fazem é muito difícil
difícil é a gente Dev fazer 1% que o Bin
faz mas é o ponto é você olhar e falar
Beleza eu quero
fazer 30% como que eu chego lá para você
ter uma ideia você que tá ouvindo e
assistindo a gente a buken consegue eles
podem fazer mais de 1000 experimentos
simultâneos a qualquer
em diferentes produtos e grupos alvos
ali de clientes então é um poder de
de vendo assim de fora né F eu acho que
é por isso que vocês trouxeram uma
pessoa da book para ajudar é que a BK
ela só funciona dentro dessa cultura e
foi por isso que a BK ela chegou onde
chegou a ponto de ela ser meio que
e intocada intocável pela airbnb que
Teoricamente ser
a empresa que meio que bateria de frente
com ela
né Seria tipo contraponto do do booking
airbnb não
consegue E aí veio um ponto assim só
sobre experimentação e teste além do
ferramental acho que um ponto que do do
da booking é o lance
da desse olhar para teste experimentação
tá de cima para baixo né é algo cultural
da mentalidade de cima para baixo não
para cima é também Mas é muito
estruturado é muito estruturado então
por exemplo essa lance de tirar deixar
uma nota pra qualidade do
experimento a gente se inspirou no deles
eles fazem isso dão uma nota de
qualidade pro experimento para que que
serve no final das contas para você ver
se você tá fazendo coisas que realmente
tem qualidade ou você tá testando por
testar sem ter sem nem construir um
experimento com um racional bom
eles têm uma ferramenta interna lá a
gente não tem a mesma ferramenta interna
que eles então vamos aqui quais do
mercado a gente pode usar para começar
mas entendo que é um ponto de partida e
a partir do momento que E aí é muito
legal assim se eu pegar a jornada Noé se
a gente pegar dois anos atrás mais ou
menos eh o VP do Zé ele falava não tem
que fazer isso coloca esse botão aqui
que não sei o qu agora ele fala É tem
que experimentar mas foi uma construção
foi beleza construíamos a experimentação
agora
gente mostra para ele o experimento que
a gente vai fazer Qual que é o resultado
como é que foi que outro experimento
derivou então a gente já consegue fazer
sobre isso né a gente fez um experimento
por exemplo que deu errado mas uma parte
dele deu certo então a gente isolou e
pegou só essa parte fez de novo
E aí fica mais fácil a conversa mas não
porque ele no primeiro momento achava
que tinha que experimentar tudo não
também tem um aprendizado né da
liderança e para mim a pessoa de produto
ela precisa também guiar esse
aprendizado de alguma forma mas guiar
com demonstração de fazendo não guiar
olha essa teoria bonita aqui não é
explicar o que é né Eh já passei por por
algumas situações que o o diretor deixou
bem claro Car eu não sei o que é
Discovery então o que que vocês estão
falando de discovery é sentar explicar a
gente fez o Discovery que a gente fez
é responder essas quatro perguntas cinco
perguntas aqui do mar k né então é é
meio que educar e de novo o STE rer não
tem obrigação de saber pensa o seguinte
ó vai pra gente falar com a galera do
financeiro
os caras vão meter um I IPA V você
vai falar o que que os caras tá
metendo louco para C deim tá criando
sigla do nada exatamente a gente
basicamente faz isso que não porque o
Iva porque o pisc fins você fala ass que
que é pisc fins rapaz vamos fazer o Jobs
Tod aí ó vamos usar Jobs Tod vamos se
pessoas nem sabem o que que são então
assim se coloca nesse lugar
também como que você aí a gente vai
voltar Num Episódio futuro falando sobre
teste de experimentação aqui F você
traga mais alguém daí não vou trazer
mais gente
aí fazer a galera que tá fazendo bem né
aí a gente pbe a galera que tá fazendo
bem ISO isso isso por favor eh eu venho
só de companhia ISO só veio só para
fazer as perguntas que você gostaria de
fazer no horário comercial isso porque
aqui você vai ser com rost eh pelo
entretenimento OK aí você fez isso como
que você como liderança
acompanha porque tem tem um ponto lá do
da sua palestra que eu achei bem
interessante é que você você vai
construindo o time você você usa esse
esse Panorama digamos assim esse painel
de maturidade para você definir e e
criar os times para resolver problemas
então pô tem aqui um um um produto uma
jornada que precisa mais de pessoas que
tenha um um viés de research mais forte
deixa eu ver aqui quem são essas pessoas
pô deixa eu levar para lá para me ajudar
a
acelerar essa etapa lá aí elas voltam Pô
eu precisa de alguém que tenha uma
execução mais eh fina deixa eu ver as é
isso né basicamente isso te ajuda a ter
mais eficiência exato É assim pensa que
recurso é sempre limitado recurso
dinheiro é sempre limitado você vai ter
um orçamento para usar eu tenho 10.000
de orçamento eu tenho que escolher onde
eu vou botar cada dinheirinho então se
você tem isso mapeado te ajuda a falar
beleza então vou botar 2.000 aqui eu vou
investir nesse lado eh tem um outro lado
por
exemplo que a gente tinha eh muito
problema na parte que era
de documentação
conseguir dar visibilidade
acompanhamento de métricas touch points
entre todo mundo então a gente foi
estruturando a área de
programa para isso acontecer uma vez que
tá estruturado pessoas falam Nossa que
alívio nem sabia eu precisava disso né
então e são as decisões assim ah eu vou
escolher não investir em design system
is é uma escolha você como líder você
vai fazer essa escolha Porque se é o que
você vai dizer eu vou trazer alguém
muito bom no design sist ou alguém muito
bom de research cara onde é o maior
buraco pra estratégia de agora research
que era um que a gente queria evolui
muito de consumir insites Então vamos
criar uma estrutura para resolver esse
problema então muito do do que eu vejo
assim é uma coisa é para você criar os
times ou colocar dedicação e outra coisa
também é para
contratar porque na hora que a gente tá
contratando eu preciso trazer pessoas
que tenham os
Skills da onde tá o meu buraco porque
essas pessoas vão botar a barra lá em
cima e elas vão puxar o restante do time
né como a gente tá falando de
experimentação voltar nesse caso a gente
contratou uma pessoa muito boa ela pode
vir falar aqui mas acho que ela não vai
querer muito boa
eh Bruna Moutinho chame ela um dia essa
menina é um
gênio
eh a gente contratou A Bru e a Bruna
ajudou a gente a criar e puxar a cultura
com outras pessoas Então ela foi
compartilhando conhecimento dividia um
pouco com um com o outro olhava Os
experimentos das outras pessoas isso
ajuda Então tem um caminho
eh e por isso que eu acho que você
quando você fala assim Ah o time não é
Senior não é Senior no qu nesse ponto
Então traz uma pessoa e cria o ambiente
aí isso vai te ajudar a melhorar Como
como que E aí pensando na evolução né OK
eu fiz lá a pesquisa eu entendi como que
tá hoje
e e eu vou atrás como liderança né como
empresa eu vou atrás das do ferramental
para poder criar os processos para
evoluir isso como que você faz a
mensuração dessa S
eh quais indicadores você acompanha
disso e e com qual
periodicidade você roda a pesquisa
novamente porque você vai ter lá foto né
pô maturidade que nem lá você mostrou em
setembro de 2023 a gente tá no dois Mas
como que você vai acompanhando Quais são
os indicadores para você falar pô a
gente tá evoluindo não estamos evoluindo
a gente faz essa pesquisa a cada TRS
meses eu vou compartilhar aqui para
mostrar que agora a gente está no três
chupa estamos no
três eu falo estamos porque devido ao
uso em da minha imagem Eu me considero
parte do Zé a gente está no três então o
que que a gente fez para evoluir do dois
pro três né então para tirar né então
vou falar sobre design design é o que
acontece workshop design é escalável e
padronizado bom os critiques precisam
acontecer né o design critique eh a
gente começa a ter
inclusive métricas de qualidade do que
tá sendo tá sendo feito handover do time
de design
eh que o próprio time de design avalia
tá não é nem uma pessoa de fora e aí o
próprio time vai subindo a barra Então
você tem outras métricas que são
paralelas né que a gente fez então a
gente colocou investiu mais em em
blueprints de
jornada investiu muito mais em pesquisa
por exemplo Então a gente tem um negócio
criação do masa do VP de negócio
inclusive ó do masa que é o VP do Zé ele
colocou que a gente tinha que falar com
os consumidores toda uma vez por semana
e a gente ia
entrevistar pediu para produto erro meu
não
fiz ele botou de
pé com time de Vamos fazer vamos fazer
time colocou de pé depois passaram pra
gente A gestão mas ele colocou de pé e E
aí criou-se o hábito de toda sexta-feira
ter cliente sendo entrevistado isso
propagou em mais
pessoas né fazendo fazendo entrevistas
então consumer insite também fo
então uma forma de medir assim como a
gente faz a cada TRS meses você tem a
evolução no ano né que é sempre ano
contra ano e você consegue quebrar por
time Então você sabe qual time que tipo
de problema tem porque os times eles
também não vão ser iguais Vai ser ótima
experimentação em todos os times se os
times são melhores tem times são piores
nesses times que são piores de
experimentação eu quero que eles evoluam
experimentação ou não faz não faz com a
natureza e aí você inclusive na hora que
tá pensando em xadrez de pessoas né indo
de uma hora para outra você começa a
considerar isso E como que como que anda
a evolução esse ano em 2025 é chegar no
4 é isso né Isso
aí é a gente tá em 3.6 em produto 3.7 em
design
então 4.2 foi foi uma a gente quer pegar
4.2 na parcial
que é o meio do ano não tá bom não tá
bom tá bom é possível joga a meta estica
pra gente conseguir chegar pô ué se for
nesse se for nisso daí no final do ano
cinco vai tá muito próximo de cinco Acho
que cinco ainda tem um
trabalho o pulo de quatro para cinco é o
mais
difícil por qu você
acha porque volta lá no material lá
vamos ver vamos voltar aqui deixa eu
voltar por que que eu acho o pulo mais
difícil olho o
cinco ISO assim
ó quando a gente fala aqui do
quatro que abrir um monte F iso na
frente sem querer quando a gente fala
aqui do quatro três e o quatro no três a
gente padronizou o processo padronizar o
processo beleza aqui a gente tem que
seguir isso então tem lá um Quality
review a gente olha a qualidade vê se tá
seguindo content se tá seguindo que
design System tem que quais os
componentes de design System então tem
uma
lógica processo ele é mais fácil de
resolver quando a gente vai pro quatro a
gente fala sobre formas sistemáticas né
ter formas sistemáticas da necessidade
do usuário e você conseguir encaixar
isso no no sistema quando a gente vai
pro cinco que esse aqui quatro eu acho
que a gente já tá próximo tá acho que
aqui a gente tá conseguindo ampliar e tá
rodando bem RMC comunica super bem
quando a gente vai pro cinco
é os times
multifuncionais
eles façam a ser parte do time de
produto então inclusive tira o PM da
posição de vaidade eu controlo o produto
não você é um grande
articulador né desse desse conjunto de
construção e você vai ter toda a
organização entendendo as necessidades
do cliente e toda a organização a gente
falar toda inclusive financeiro áreas de
apoio
RH então assim isso tem um desafio maior
então por isso eu não acho que sim que é
impossível mas eu acho que o c a gente
consegue em 26 só o c o cinco o cinco a
gente pode dizer que o cinco seria uma
mudança
eh profunda na cultura de uma empresa ou
não é porque o cinco não é sobre mudar a
área de produto até o quatro você vai na
área de
produto é sua responsabilidade de alguma
forma responsabilidade daquele time que
tá ali o cinco você precisa ser capaz de
até o quatro ter melhorado tanto o
resultado E o impacto que cara no cinco
as pessoas começam a olhar e falar por
que que daqui a gente tem que importar
pro
todo por isso que eu acho que o cinco é
mais difícil mas o quatro ele é o que é
um pouco mais tá na sua mão assim o
quatro é o que valida o a
hipótese exato para para escalar pra
empresa inteira e uma das coisas que a
gente tinha visto É na hora que você
você chega cha no nível C de maturidade
as empresas que tão né nesse nível de
maturidade que isso foi uma pesquisa do
invision inclusive o resultado Ele é
quatro vezes melhor o impacto Ele é
quatro vezes
maior então Teoricamente né tipo no a
gente já tá tendo Impacto muito maior o
produto tá muito melhor as entregas o
resultado tá vindo né então tudo tem uma
consequência só que na hora do nível C
realmente é quando fica exponencial
caminhando pro pro pro final of eh todos
os links todas as citações menções links
eh que a f eh compartilhou com a gente
ou mencionou tipo pesquisa do invision
vai est aqui na descrição do episódio
para que você tá ouvindo e assistindo a
gente possa consumir também siga também
a Fernanda faria no no Linkedin Manda um
oi F quero saber mais sobre eh isso MV
cupom eh óbvio o carnaval tá chegando e
a gente sabe tem muito cupom no Zé tem
muito cupom no Zé se você for usuário do
Zé você pedi sempre você gan um monte de
C Nossa olha só Qual que é a relação e
a a relação a influência e a
responsabilidade de cada
nível do time de produto e design nessa
evolução de mat
O PM ele precisa ok tá comprado e fazer
tudo o processo usar as ferramentas E
demonstrar né ali uma evolução o GPM o
Lead o head eh a diretoria o VP o CPO
como que é eh o papel e responsabilidade
de cada nível cada papel nessa nessa
área de produto e Design em relação à
evolução da maturidade penso o seguinte
ali a gente mede por time né nível de
maturidade assim
então basicamente a responsabilidade tá
PMs e PDS assim né a maior
responsabilidade tá no PMs e PDS para
mim desse quem impacta mesmo Quem gera
Impacto
pmpd para cima a gente gera menos
impacto em massa e consegue muito mais
abrir o futuro
eh então
o que eu vejo e não é uma jornada você
acha que pô padronizar processo na hora
que você põe um processo a galera fica
feliz não a galera
odeia E aí é muito conversa ida e volta
para poder ajustar um processo que faz
sentido mas no começo você toma
pedrada você tem que aguentar pedrado a
j fala isso a falou isso em algum
podcast do a Júlia Souza da dando bem
ela falou
que você é resistente ao processo aí
depois que o processo começa a funcionar
e que você faz uso dele aí você vê que
você precisava sua vida
melhorou mas é natural do ser humano
então No começo sim quando a gente
começou a padronizar foi quase uma
revolução ass
né do time o que a gente fez foi parar
para ouvir Tá bom então vamos lá por e
sim tinham coisas que tinham que ser
ajustadas que não faziam sentido e
conforme você vai melhorando o processo
também vai automatizando mais coisas vai
deixando mais prático mais visível e tal
então o que eu diria para PMs e PDS
assim que de fato quem impacta tá Quem
gera Impacto porque quem tá todo dia com
stakholder quem é isso tem muito mais
amplitude do que um líder né Você tem 10
PMs para uma liderança são uns 10 PMs
impactam muito mais do que só essa uma
liderança né em termos de construção de
Cultura então quando a gente fala sobre
Impacto é esse time que gera Impacto mas
é esse time que precisa est flexível
também sabe porque a liderança quer
chegar a liderança não tá fazendo isso
porque nossa é uma vontade que saiu da
minha cabeça não eu tô fazendo isso que
é justamente para dar mais autonomia pro
time inclusive nesse processo né Se o
time tem mais autonomia vai trab
trabalha melhor então a clareza do do
por você tá fazendo aquelas coisas acho
que é muito importante assim dizendo
cara a gente montou o número a gente tá
aqui a gente quer chegar aqui isso aqui
eu se um time para não sei
aqui e Pô a gente quer que vocês sejam
esse time Então as pessoas se engajam na
jornada também Ô Fê muito obrigado pelo
pelo seu tempo pela sua agenda que é
concorrida porque você cuida do Brasil e
mais 10 países da América de boa você
pegou meu último dia de férias aí ó
ótimo é isso e Mas você volta mais vezes
aqui durante o ano certo volto pego os
assuntos e a gente vai falando e aí eu
trago pessoas também que estão fazendo
coisas
legais perfeito perfeito ISS de host é
muito mais legal do que muito melhor se
a gente não tem responsabilidade nenhuma
é só fazer pergunta e Oi F Muito
obrigado
e você que ouviu e assistiu até aqui
todos os na descrição siga pelo amor do
Senhor Jesus Cristo o
Nazareno Fernanda faria no linked mand
Oi eu sou
imaturo me
amadurece só essa frase aí enf ou manda
um tem vaga porque eu sei que tem vaga
lá
na então link também das vagas vai est
aqui na descrição Mas é isso muito
obrigado eh sempre uma honra um
privilégio eh conversar com você e ter
você como amiga Isso é incrível Obrigado
você a nossa linda amizade beijo beijos
tchau fui